so i think what i've learned is that
all the secrecy around ufos
was for good reason because we didn't
know what it was then we thought it was
aliens and we realized holy [ __ ] they're
not aliens or something else and then
we're like what do we do we need to
study this understand this we need to
build a
weaponry or something on a way to push
back we got to do something but it might
take like 70 years
and then like 70 years later i'm like
sitting there like
hey i got an idea let's talk about this
and some of the people are like it's
time to talk about it others were like
it's not time but um it's nature so we
got to kind of confront it regardless
but it's very real it's insanely bigger
than you think it is it's not just a few
things in the sky it's
very very big i got brought over to
italy uh some dudes with italian
intelligence and vatican and u.n they
were all there went to military base had
these briefings and they showed me a map
of the mediterranean and what was
happening was is on the coast of sicily
all these like apartments were like
catching on fire like a microwave boom
some books boom like the [ __ ] couch
boom and so the government came in and
they're like what the [ __ ] is going on
here so they quarantine the area get
everyone to leave and they're going why
are things catching on fire they
detected they detected these
um energy beams energy weapons or
something that were coming off of the
way out in the ocean in the
mediterranean
so
this dude gets uh he he was a colonel at
the time and he was in charge oh what
they looked out and saw were ufos were
out in the ocean [ __ ] around so the
head of the ufo program and the head of
the italian navy seals get on an
unmarked civilian helicopter
and just fly out to go see what's going
on out there
as they're flying a ufo pops out of the
ocean and shoots their [ __ ]
helicopter down i have the documents on
the italian intelligence letterhead i
talked to the dude the two dudes i was
in the meeting with that were on the
[ __ ] helicopter i have pictures of
the helicopter being chased by the ufo
and all the damage that was done to it
with some type of microwave weapon or
something
and
what they found out was
that there were airplanes and other
helicopters kind of in the area but the
ufo knew that those dudes were looking
for him it's like they can read their
minds it's like we have drones that fly
around and listen to people's like cell
phones and [ __ ]
they do it with thought you know imagine
in advance sorry we don't need to listen
to your phone i'll just [ __ ] point my
dish
at stevo and i can hear as well it's
[ __ ] he's thinking of some weird [ __ ]
you know like right right shoot him down
you know so um it's it's just absolutely
wild so the map they showed me of the
mediterranean
they go these are all the hot spots of
what's happening with ufos just recently
and there was hundreds of marks hundreds
all over the ocean they're
just things happening everywhere
every day it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
there's a big base under puerto rico off
the i think i think they're probably i
would imagine and all over the place in
our oceans yeah it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude